-Yesterday, Politico
published a draft opinion
that revealed the Supreme Court
has decided to overturn
the landmark case
Roe versus Wade
and end abortion rights.
Many of us
are disheartened by this
and are struggling to understand
what can be done to protect
women's reproductive freedom.
To help us out, please welcome
two representatives
from the Democratic
National Committee.
-Thank you, Seth Meyers.
Now, America, we understand
things are looking down.
-For a lot of us,
the future seems dim.
-But we, the Democratic
National Committee,
are here to reassure you
that we will get through this.
-We have a plan.
Democrats are going to show up
in record numbers
this upcoming election
and vote, vote, vote.
-Oh, wow. I mean, that really
makes me breathe easier.
So you really think we have
a chance of stopping this?
-[Bleep] no!
-What the [bleep]
are you talking about?!
-I thought you said
you had a plan!
-We don't have a plan!
-We're Democrats!
We can barely tie
our own [bleep] shoes!
-This guy thinks we have a plan.
-A plan.
-But we need you to,
I don't know,
maybe provide
some guidance here.
-Okay. Okay. You're right.
It's not over.
We hold the majority
in Congress.
We can pass legislation
that will keep abortion legal.
-Yes. There's still hope.
-See? That's what
I'm talking about.
So you really think
there's still hope?
-[Bleep] no!
-Can you even hear yourself?!
-You sound insane right now!
-The legislative branch?!
Have you heard of Joe Manchin?!
We can't get anything
through there!
-But you said!
-"Buh-buh-buh-buh but you said!"
Listen to this idiot!
-We're Democrats!
We couldn't find something
to write with
in a pencil factory!
-Okay, so this situation
is completely hopeless.
-[ Both whispering ]
-Okay. Okay. Maybe not.
There's always
the judicial branch.
-That's right.
We can fight this in court
and take it all the way
to the Supreme Court
and get them to reinstate
Roe v. Wade.
-Wait a minute. Isn't the
Supreme Court the problem?
-You're damn right it is!
There's like 17 conservatives
on the Supreme Court!
-There's only
supposed to be 9 justices,
but somehow they got like
17 conservatives on there!
And, like,
30 of them are Catholic!
And 20 of them
are super Catholic!
-Oh, my God! We're [bleep]!
-We're so [bleep]!
-Oh, my God!
We are totally
and completely useless!
-Okay, come on.
There's got to be something!
-Yes. You're right.
Everyone take out your phone
and text "We're [bleep]"
to 02024
and throw your phone
out the window!
-No! Something real!
-[ Groans ]
-[ Both whispering ]
-Okay. Okay. You know what?
There's still
the executive branch.
We can get Joe Biden
to issue an executive order.
-Okay. That's a great idea.
He'll do that, right?
-[bleep] no!
-That guy can't do anything!
He can't forgive three dollars
in student loans!
-The guy can't even maintain
the back of his haircut!
He's losing the fight
against his own mullet!
But you think he's gonna win
the fight for abortion rights?!
-Alright, alright. Look.
You guys,
you can't give up, okay?
I mean, it's easy
to blame Democrats
for being ineffective,
but it's important to remember
that this is the result
of a decades-long plan
by Republicans.
And, sure, maybe Democrats
haven't been as effective
as we've wanted them to be,
but when your backs
are to the wall,
I know you have what it takes
to get this done.
-You do?
-Well...
-I knew it! We're [bleep]!
-We're totally [bleep]!
-Two representatives from
the Democratic National
Committee, everybody.
Why are you being proud?
Why are you posing?
Stop posing!